[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour vous le président Coty est
conduit à sa dernière demeure le pays
joint l'hommage de ses profonds regrets
de sa vie vestime au chagrin qui éteint
la famille du disparu et à la flexion de
la grande ville du Havre tels étaient
les premières paroles prononcées par le
général de Gaulle devant les plus hautes
personnalités de l'État et une foule
énorme rassemblée place de l'Hôtel de
Ville
[Musique]
après le défilé des troupes terre marine
et air le cortège funèbre a gagné la
petite église Saint-Vincent cependant
que la foule s'était massée tout le long
du parcours
la présence du chef de l'État aux
obsèques du président cotique a été
l'expression d'un hommage solennel de la
France tout entier
et une foule anonyme silencieuse une
foule de gens simple telle que les
aimait le président Coty se précèdent
entre l'église et le cimetière
Sainte-Marie cachant mal son émotion
président René Coty avait conclu le chef
de l'État pour toujours votre sommeil et
celui du juste et le respect du peuple
français entoure votre mémoire
[Musique]
le président fulber Yulu a ouvert les
fêtes de l'indépendance de la République
du Congo le plus traditionnellement du
monde par une remise de décoration
il donnait assister ensuite au défilé
des troupes sans lequel il n'y a pas de
véritable fête nationale
[Musique]
ainsi après deux ans d'indépendance le
Congo offre l'image d'un jeune pays
africain qui poursuit sans heurts son
évolution
c'est ce qu'a pu constater le colonel
Mobutu venu en voisin de Léopoldine
de l'Armée du Salut aux enfants des
écoles le pittoresque bien sûr n'a pas
manqué à ce défilé qui alignait derrière
l'armée les délégations de toutes les
formations syndicales sportives et
folklory
[Applaudissements]
Brazzaville dans le même temps vivait
l'expérience moderne de la télévision
installé dans des bâtiments provisoires
l'émetteur de télécongo a fonctionné
pour la première fois avec l'aide des
techniciens français de l'office de
coopération radiophonique speedrine
speaker tout était en place
le président fulber Yulu a inauguré les
émissions en prononçant une allocution
où il a souligné la part de la
télévision dans la diffusion des idées
et des techniques
et devant les premiers postes installés
dans la ville la population de
Brazzaville a manifesté une joyeuse
curiosité pour le petit écran
[Musique]
signe des temps nouveaux un poste de
télévision présidait le bal donné au
palais présidentiel au soir des fêtes de
l'indépendance
[Musique]
au palais d'appel d'armes vient de
s'éteindre celle qui régnait à 58 ans
sur la Hollande Rennes à 10 ans Willemin
n'avait véritablement commencé son règne
qu'en 1898 au jour de son couronnement
la petite histoire nous la montre
patinant avec sa fille Juliana la Belle
Époque aimait le patin à glace
Rennes et sol reine en Europe après la
mort de Victoria willemine eût une très
haute idée de sa mission ce qui ne
l'empêcha pas de l'accomplir avec une
constante bonne humeur à la plus grande
satisfaction de ces sujets
1940 la trouva indomptable de tous les
rois en exil c'est l'homme le plus
courageux dire à Churchill de Willemin
exilé avec Juliana et son retour dans
une Hollande terriblement meurtrie fut
un triomphal hommage à la noble qu'elle
avait adopté le peuple hollandais avait
revu avec émotion sa reine passait en
revue avec sa simplicité de toujours
victorieuse en 1948 will el mine avait
annoncé son abdication en faveur de sa
fille Julian
depuis lors on l'a revit rarement en
public elle s'y montra essentiellement
pour retrouver les anciens combattants
et ceux qui avaient bien mérité de son
pays
avec le souvenir de la reine Willemin
morte à 82 ans au palais d'appel d'arme
c'est aussi un demi-siècle d'histoire
que la Hollande évoque aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à Londres livreur et pâtissier se sont
succédés à la porte de la demeure de
hype par gate qui habite un autre héros
du demi-siècle Winston Churchill Lady
Churchill a recueilli pour lui les
fleurs qu'on ne manque jamais chaque
année de lui apporter
Winston Churchill dont la carrière
commence avec le siècle vient de fêter
ses 88 ans
[Musique]
à Londres le ministre de l'ère
britannique et l'ambassadeur de France
ont signé l'accord qui doit aboutir en
1970 à la mise en service de l'appareil
supersonique franco-anglais Concorde
dérivés de Caravelle les constructeurs
britanniques auront plus spécialement la
charge des réacteurs 4 bristols ségly
Allen plus 593 d'une poussée de 13
tonnes chacun
quant à la France elle a fourni les
pleins de cet appareil à elle Delta dont
la version long courrier transportera 90
passagers de Paris à New York en trois
heures battant le soleil dans sa course
départ midi arrivée 9h du matin
[Musique]
les récentes expériences nucléaires
souterraines du Nevada ont ouvert de
nouveaux horizons on envisage d'utiliser
une succession de semblables cratères
400 mètres de diamètre pour creuser des
canaux géants par ailleurs ces
explosions réalisées à plus de 200
mètres sous terre ne laisse pas de
résidus radioactif dangereux
[Musique]
les médecins israéliens ont mis au point
un dispositif léger et mobile qui permet
d'étudier les réactions du cœur humain
sur les lieux même du travail ce
dispositif est utilisé ici dans les
zones arides du désert du [ __ ] où les
conditions de travail sont
particulièrement pénibles
l'intérêt de ces appareils est de
transmettre par radio à un poste
d'enregistrement central tous les
renseignements concernant la santé
d'hommes en pleine activité
[Musique]
les bandes d'enregistrement sont
conservées et restitue à la demande du
savant toutes les caractéristiques à
étudier
elles permettent aux médecins d'établir
un diagnostic précis sur le comportement
des individus appelés à travailler dans
des lieux exceptionnels auxquels
certains risqueraient d'être incapables
de s'adapter
[Musique]
quand on a 18 ans qu'on est charmante
qu'on a une famille préoccupée de
l'avenir on peut changer aujourd'hui à
débuter dans le monde il n'est pas sans
intérêt que l'on s'adonne au dessin
qu'on prépare les beaux-arts sous
l'autorité d'un maître réputé
le yoga est également une discipline
bien portée il a entre autres avantages
celui d'éviter que la tête ne tourne
ce qui est bien entendu un danger
permanent il n'est pas mauvais non plus
de nourrir une passion égale pour Brahms
et pour Johnny Hallyday ce phénomène
Marie-Christine est bien Ghislaine ou
Bénédicte et mieux toutes ces conditions
remplies on peut choisir sa robe de base
vienne les essayages essayez essayez
essayez on apprendra encore la révérence
indispensable aux débutants et on
recommencera sans se rebuter
on devrait également s'abandonner à ceux
qui ont la charge et le secret de la
beauté nous voulons parler des maîtres
coiffeurs et aussi de ces bourreaux de
pieds charmants et de mains blanches les
pédicures et manucures hautement
qualifiées
ainsi pareil on est la débutant
autrement dit l'une des 400 jeunes
filles que la haute couture la Haute
Coiffure la joaillerie et tout le
commerce parisien de luxe ont choisi
comme ambassadrice au Théâtre National
de l'Opéra il a fallu deux heures pour
permettre à toutes les compagnes de
Marie-Christine d'être présentée à ce
tout Paris que rien n'est tonne deux
heures c'est bien long mais elle compte
naît tout de même pour chacune cette
demi minute de gloire
[Musique]
et puis à minuit on eu quand même la
permission de danser la valse d'abord il
faut respecter ses classiques
et puis enfin le twist de la liberté
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que 400 débutants ont vécu à
l'Opéra une soirée inoubliable et que
les parents n'ont pas fini d'en parler
[Musique]
si on a l'unanimité de Monsieur tente au
poste de secrétaire général permanent
des Nations Unies aura surpris et
soulagé à la fois l'Union soviétique
abandonnait ainsi son projet antérieur
de troïka et du même coup cette élection
qui consacrait le rôle de médiateur de
Monsieur tende dans l'affaire de Cuba
est apparu comme un signe de détente
entre l'Est et l'Ouest
[Musique]
le maréchal Tito est décidé de passer
ses vacances en Union soviétique et que
Monsieur krokchaf soit venu l'accueillir
lui et son épouse au milieu de tous les
honneurs est aussi le signe d'une autre
des temps après une brouille de six ans
la glace semble bien rompue entre Moscou
et Belgrade
de Monsieur coachov s'est produit au
moment même où le maréchal Pitot était
l'objet de violente critique de la Chine
[Applaudissements]
en des milliers de Hollandais venus de
toutes les régions du pays les
funérailles solennelles de la princesse
Willemin se sont déroulés à d'elle la
princesse willemine avait insisté pour
que tout se passe le plus simplement
possible la reine Juliana et les
princesses étaient en plan et le Roi
Baudouin et la reine Fabiola cachait mal
leur émotion
toute une nation pleurait en rendant un
dernier hommage à cette reine qui oser
les plus sombres de l'histoire des
Pays-Bas avait soutenu son peuple avec
un courage simple et une fois
inébranlable
[Musique]
devant les 2000 paires conciliaires
réunis à Saint-Pierre de Rome Jean 23 à
clos la première session du concile
écumelique
le travail ne s'arrêtera pas déclarer le
pape une tâche d'une grande importance
nous attend encore Rome retrouvera en
effet les pères venus des quatre coins
du monde en septembre 1963
[Musique]
en France l'installation de la deuxième
assemblée de la 5e République à animer
les travées de l'hémicycle du Palais
Bourbon
les députés devaient entendre le
discours du chanoine Kir que ses 87 ans
désignaient pour ouvrir la séance rôle
traditionnellement réservé aux doyen
d'âge
la réélection au fauteuil de présidents
de Monsieur Chaban-Delmas ne faisait de
doute pour personne mais les 287
suffrages qui allaient se porter sur son
nom devait permettre d'évaluer la
majorité gouvernementale
le lendemain devait apporter l'image du
nouveau gouvernement réuni pour un
premier Conseil des ministres autour du
général de Gaulle une image assez peu
différente de celle du précédent puisque
le ministère Pompidou n'a subi que
quelques remaniements et ne comprend que
trois nouveaux venus
[Musique]
à Tours 8e journée internationale du
film de court-métrage au programme sans
film de 21 nations le Grand Prix que
devait remettre Monsieur Michel foret
Cormeray directeur du Centre du Cinéma
est allé au réalisateur polonais Roman
Polanski pour son film les mammifères
Pierrelatte c'est toi le distacé c'est
un coin de Provence bien que proche de
la Nationale 7 on aurait pu croire cette
cité vouée à sommeiller à l'ombre de son
clocher avec ses petites ruées son
unique facteur
or voici qu'il y a 4 ans le Commissariat
à l'énergie atomique choisi Pierrelatte
pour y installer son usine de séparation
des isotopes
70k franchissent aujourd'hui chaque jour
le contrôle sévère de l'usinatomique
pour y amener 3000 ouvriers ils seront 5
ou 6000 en 1967 réaction en chaîne si
l'on peut dire des entreprises
satellites s'édifient dans le voisinage
[Musique]
si bien que le maire de Pierrelatte
s'apprête à compter dans 5 ans 20 000
administrés alors qu'il n'en n'avait que
3448 en 1954 dès à présent la vie du
chef-lieu de canton de la Drôme en est
bouleversé les bancs ont déjà pris
position
tous les boutiques ont rajeuni où sont
en train de le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tandis qu'on apprécie déjà les plaisirs
des grandes villes
s'ensuit stationnement réglementé etc
etc l'ancienne poste c'est doublé d'un
bâtiment provisoire où les demoiselles
du téléphone affrontent maintenant un
standard de l'importance de celui d'une
ville comme Montélimar
[Musique]
quantum facteur on la multiplié par 5 et
personne ne chauffe
c'est que le paysage a sensiblement
changé des immeubles de 15 étages et ont
poussé comme des champignons et ce n'est
pas fini l'usine atomique a changé le
destin de Pierrelatte mais Pierrelatte
et plus qu'un exemple c'est l'image même
d'un État qui se veut moderne en
édifiant aujourd'hui sa propre industrie
atomique
[Musique]
un anniversaire vient de passer inaperçu
le centenaire du chapeau melon il est
vrai qu'on ne le porte plus guère
aujourd'hui sur les Champs-Élysées et
quand on le porte
pourtant lorsqu'il y a 100 ans à un
chapelier londonien eu confectionné pour
un gentleman farmer du nom de William
coq le couvre chef inédit le monde
entier l'adopta d'enthousiasme du moins
le monde portant moustache
il faut avouer que le melon apportait ce
jaune c'est quoi qui manquait encore
pour faire d'un homme ordinaire le
Conquérant sur de lui
[Musique]
les premiers chasseurs d'images le
coiffeur
il fut de tous les duels célèbres
[Musique]
la foule l'arbora comme le signe visible
de sa bonne conscience et l'on ne vit
jamais sans doute un âge si bien rendu à
l'exemple de Clémenceau les hommes
politiques l'adoptaient
avec Aristide Briand il présida ainsi au
destinée de la France comme un symbole
rassurant il devint même si banal qu'une
certaine police le portait pour passer
inaperçu
et puis il arrive à ce qu'il devait
arriver les foules versatiles le renier
pour le chapeau mu d'abord pour les
têtes nues en Suisse c'était dans la fin
non pourtant il reste à fidèlement
révéler sur les champs de course
de lointaines expéditions lancées vers
un Pérou inconnu le trouvèrent au détour
du chemin sur des têtes de femmes
[Applaudissements]
les Frères Jacques l'inclure dans leur
silhouette
et voici qu'aujourd'hui la mode il
revient mais cette fois ce sont les
femmes qui s'en sont un par
mais voici 100 ans le chapeau melon
vient de retrouver ainsi un regain de
gloire mais que durera t-il le temps
d'un caprice sans doute
[Musique]
si les bijoux sont de tous les temps
Vulcain déjà travaillé pour les dieux
chaque époque a eu son style dans son
atelier parisien Jean-Claude Champagnat
est un des créateurs d'aujourd'hui qu'il
faut placer à la pointe de l'avant-garde
entre ses mains naissent non des bijoux
fantaisie mais des bijoux qui ont un
impacter une fantaisie folle on ne
s'étonnera pas de les voir passer tour à
tour du figuratif à l'abstrait
feuille d'or ciselée grenat c'est une
bague qui s'inspire prosaïquement du
fruit du mûrier
[Musique]
la nuit étoilé a inspiré cette
architecture d'or et de corail
fleur d'émeraude sur fond noir
[Musique]
lac blanche or et rubis une bague russe
née à Paris
mais ce n'est pas tout on peut dire que
l'oeuvre de Jean-Claude Champagnat tient
à la fois de l'art floral issue de
l'École de Nancy et des mobiles de
Calder
[Musique]
des bagues vertigineuses en somme et
dont certaines mettront à votre doigt
mesdames la marque de notre temps
atomique et spatial
[Musique]
devant les Bordelais les footballeurs et
moi culotte noir maillot à manche
blanche ont subi une nouvelle défaite à
quoi bon bien joué au football à quoi
bon être la meilleure équipe française
si on ne gagne pas de match en 2000 en
pure perte et on sait marquer un but sur
contre-attaque voilà qui est fait
Monsieur Papa Numéro 9 a beau se
multiplier varier les changements de
rythme appelé akesby du geste pour lui
donner un ballon en or ça ne va plus
pour Reims
[Applaudissements]
il est vrai que les Bordelais ont une
tactique bien à eux ils se replient sur
leur copie
[Applaudissements]
et de temps à autre c'est la
contre-attaque sèche rapide incisive
comme un trait
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme cela que les Bordelais
marquent au début
[Applaudissements]
les rémois qui s'accommodent mal de
cette manière ne savent pas trouver la
parade en voici une nouvelle preuve 3-0
pour board
[Applaudissements]
c'est décourageant pour les rémois qui
pendant vont déborder la défense
bordelaise la classe a fini toujours par
payer mais un Buré moi contre trois buts
bordelais en langage clair cela veut
dire défaite
au Palais de l'Élysée l'arbre de Noël a
poussé un peu en avant mêlée aux enfants
des collaborateurs de la présidence 200
élèves méritants des écoles de Paris ont
été les autres avis de Madame De Gaulle
et du chef de l'État qui a abandonné
quelques instants les soucis de sa
charge pour jouer les Père Noël
[Musique]
devant un auditoire spécialisé monsieur
Pisani ministre de l'Agriculture a
commenté les chances qu'offre au
cultivateurs français l'entrée en
vigueur du Marché Commun agricole
problème à l'ordre du jour pour les
différents gouvernements européens
[Musique]
le marché commun a bien entendu alimenté
la conversation du dernier week-end de
franco-anglais qui a réuni à Rambouillet
monsieur Mac Millan et le général de
Gaulle mais il fut aussi beaucoup
question de la défense occidentale qui
faisait précisément l'objet de la
session parisienne du Conseil atlantique
[Musique]
le général norstatt qui quitte le
commandement suprême à la fin de l'année
et Monsieur dinerask auront eu la
satisfaction d'y voir leur conseil suivi
puisque les ministres des 15 ont d'un
commun accord jugé nécessaire
d'accroître l'efficacité des forces
classiques de l'Alliance c'est là le
point essentiel d'un communiqué
optimiste
précisément ces forces classiques celles
du moins de la France et de l'Angleterre
venaient de se produire sur le terrain
[Musique]
l'opération cross Chanel qui s'est
déroulée dans le sud-ouest de la France
a mis à contribution des hélicoptères
britanniques et français Nord 2501 et
astings dans une opération destinée à
traduire l'aptitude des unités à entrer
en action loin de leur base de départ
ce qui fut fait à la plus grande
satisfaction précisant des observateurs
[Applaudissements]
il reste que la France comme
l'Angleterre n'ont pas renoncé à leur
force de frappe nucléaire
la Royale Navy vient pour sa part de
procéder aux essais du premier
sous-marin atomique made in England pour
l'instant seul la propulsion et
nucléaire mais il est probable que
l'armement suivra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lauréate 1962 du prix Suzanne biancetti
Corinne marchand est la 20e étoile
naissante que les auteurs de films ont
choisi de couronner et leur président
chargé du discours d'usage a eu une bien
agréable tâche à remplir
[Musique]
c'est une tâche plus austère que c'était
fixé les juristes réunis à Paris par le
colloque de droit cinématographique
mettre à l'heure du marché commun le
cinéma des différents pays d'Europe qui
totalisent deux milliards de spectateurs
par an
quand Apple Émile Victor grand
spécialiste du Groenland il s'est fixé
pour tâche d'apporter l'aire du pôle sur
les Champs-Élysées un certain air de
Paul tout au moins moyennant quoi le
drugstore s'est muet en campement
d'explorateurs du Grand Nord n'y a-t-il
pas que l'illusion qui compte
[Musique]
voici de nouveau Noël Noël qui donne au
plus majestueuses cathédrales comme aux
églises les plus humbles leur voix les
plus joyeux d'un goût de la chrétienté à
l'autre cette nuit-là des dizaines de
milliers de cloches et graineront leur
chandelles les graisses dans la tour sud
de Notre-Dame de Paris le célèbre
bourdon sera exceptionnellement sonné à
la volée
[Musique]
cette maîtresse cloche de treston qui
porte le nom d'Emmanuel arithmé les
grandes heures de la capitale
à la fin du siècle dernier a retenti
pour la première fois où sacré-cœur la
voix d'une des plus grosses cloches
connues celle de la Savoyarde 19
[Musique]
les vieux Parisiens n'ont pas oublié sa
traversée de Paris sur un char tiré par
28 chevaux entre deux haies de flambeaux
et 200 000 personnes
depuis 13 siècles les cloches ont été si
intimement mêlées au grand moment de la
vie des hommes quels ont leur art
privilège de se voir conférer le baptême
qu'elles ont une personnalité propre une
naissance une vie et une main
et un destin étrange les fait souvent
finir au lieu même où elles sont nées
les fonderies de cloches ont presque
toutes disparues l'une d'elles subsiste
encore en Normandie à l'endroit même où
elle fut créée en 1150 par l'Ordre des
Templiers
[Musique]
rien n'a changé ici dans ces moules dans
quelques-uns datent du Moyen-Âge sont
coulées dans toutes les langues les
inscriptions qui accompagneront les
cloches dans tous les pays du monde
[Musique]
comme au Moyen-Âge on atteint les vins
favorables le tirage est bon le four est
allumé
[Musique]
pour éviter qu'il n'éclate sous la
pression du métal en fusion les moules
sont enterrés dans une fosse et la terre
soigneusement tassée
la température atteint 1400 degrés
dernier instant on ajoute l'État
[Musique]
sur un signe du maître fondeur le métal
coule à flot
[Musique]
les habitants du voisinage ne manquent
jamais de venir assister à cette coulée
comme autrefois les rois les cloches
naissent toujours un public
sans le soufre et la glace calcinée
[Musique]
dans quelques jours naîtra une cloche
ternaire rugueuse LED comme un
nouveau-né avant la toilette mais demain
dans la nuit de Noël sa voix sera pure
joyeuse lorsque sonneront les douze
coups de minuit
[Musique]
mais dans le même temps où elle
appellera leurs parents à la messe la
voix des cloches d'une église
campagnarde de réveillera dans leur lit
les petits enfants du bourg
pour eux comme pour des millions
d'enfants ce sera le signal secret du
grand émerveillement
[Musique]
car la nuit de Noël ce sera toujours
cela le son joyeux d'une cloche une
bûche qui brûle un sapin illuminé et
tout autour les visages radieux des
enfants éblouis
[Musique]
les chanteurs de Saint-Eustache ont
beaucoup faits pour le renom de cette
église parisienne connue dans le monde
entier et c'est de loin qu'on est venu
entendre le concert qu'ils viennent de
consacrer à l'oeuvre de Haendel sous la
direction du père Martin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces chanteurs sont les continuateurs
d'une grande tradition car si cette
Eustache est considéré comme l'une des
plus belles églises de Paris elle est
également chère aux amateurs de musique
Lully si Maria on y célébra les obsèques
de rameaux et de la mère de Mozart
Berlioz irrévéla son TDM liste y joua sa
messe de grand
[Musique]
à son arrivée à New York les
photographes n'ont plus admirer qu'une
de ces reproductions la Joconde ne
devint pas quitter comme on sait sa
caisse d'aluminium jamais passagère venu
du Vieux Continent n'aura été entouré
d'autant d'attention jalouse que Mona
Lisa on avait prévu un camion blindé et
climatisé escorté par 50 policiers
le printemps il est vrai que la toile de
Léonard de Vinci vaut plus que le
paquebot France qu'il a transporté ce
qui force le respect
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise qu'a vécu le Sénégal n'a duré
que 48 heures la tentative du président
du Conseil Mamadou Dia d'imposait sa
volonté à l'Assemblée régulièrement élu
à échouer quelques heures après son
investissement l'Assemblée nationale
était dégagée par les troupes fidèles au
président singes
d'autre part les installations de la
radio avaient vu les adversaires tour à
tour maître du micro mais malgré les
interventions de différentes troupes
personne ne parvenait à achever son
appel au peuple
le lendemain matin monsieur dia
regagnait sa villa il avait beau à
ranguer quelques partisans les jeux
étaient faits car le peuple sénégalais
était resté fidèle au président de la
République Léopold Sédar Senghor
les représentants de la nation ont été
expulsés de leur lieu de réunion et
plusieurs ont été arrêtés déclaré le
président singor j'ai réquisitionné les
forces militaires car le dernier mot
doit rester à la loi
les Sénégalais avaient pris conscience
des dangers provoqués par l'entreprise
de subversion en envahissant l'Assemblée
nationale ils entendaient protéger leur
députés et en acclamant mettre la midget
président de l'Assemblée il confirmait
leur attachement au président singor en
48 heures le Sénégal achevé sa
révolution tentative de coup d'état
épuration et réforme tendantes au régime
présidentiel
et pourtant pendant ces événements à
l'ombre des clochers des églises ultra
modernes de la capitale du Sénégal les
préparatifs de Noël ont suivi leurs
cours tranquilles et les voûtes toutes
blanches ont retentit des champs
traditionnels curieusement rythmées par
les voisins infantiles
[Musique]
lancer au mois d'août mariner II a donc
accompli la mission fixée par les
techniciens américains il a transmis
toute une série d'observations faites à
30 000 km de Vénus
[Musique]
renseignement précieux puisque l'homme
n'est pas presse en doute d'y aller voir
lui-même par contre le voyage pour la
lune semble imminent sera pour 1963
[Musique]
ce n'est pas anticipé beaucoup en tout
cas que de vous convier dès aujourd'hui
au voyage sur notre satellite confort
d'abord vous aurez pris la précaution de
retenir une fusée couchette
et par une belle nuit terrestre vous
aurez commencé de la façon la plus
classique qui soit cette petite
excursion de 384
000 km imagée d'après les dernières
observations astronomiques
au petit déjeuner vous découvrirez par
le hublot des cratères désolé
[Musique]
l'apparition des grands cirques lunaires
vous apprendra que le terme du voyage
est proche
avant d’alunir notre pilote s'installera
sur orbite tourisme pour vous permettre
de voir se dérouler sous vos yeux cette
mer des pluies dont la particularité est
d'être d'une aridité totale
[Musique]
devant vous ce dressera la grande chaîne
des à peines lunaires haute montagne
dont certains sommets culminent à plus
de 8000 mètres
tout à coup vous serez en face du mur
droit sorte de Falaise robe de 800
mètres qui s'étend sur des centaines de
kilomètres
enfin sur les plaines poussiéreuses vous
verrez briller le fameux clair de terre
[Musique]
Paris compte 61 clubs différents du club
des choses au club des fumeuses de pipes
ou au club des timides le club des
solitaires lui à cette particularité
concis écrase un sage n'a-t-il pas dit
c'est au milieu de la foule qu'on se
sent seul quoi qu'il en soit si
solitaires triés sur le volet rêver du
titre envier semble-t-il de Miss
solitude pourquoi elles l'ont dit
nettement
représentant cette élection de trouver
peut-être
une jeune homme qui freine mon bonheur
et le rose élu qu'en pense-t-elle
pourquoi étiez vos candidats au titre de
Miss solitude pourquoi être Miss
solitude et bien pour faciliter les
relations et connaître des gens
est-ce que vous pensez que votre
programme est en bonne voie oui je le
pense
[Musique]
en très bonne voie même qui donc a dit
l'homme n'est pas fait pour vivre seul
les solitaires non plus
[Musique]
il faut dire que les nuits de Paris ne
manquent pas de pôle d'attraction en
cette fin d'année pour fasciner ceux qui
sont à jouer les noctambules le Lido
pour sa part a offert à Monsieur Roger
Frey à Michel Morgan à Jean-Claude
Brialy la nouvelle revue de Pierre-Louis
Guérin une personnalité au mètre carré
grant aimait le ferrer en vedette
américaine et un brillant spectacle sur
la scène
[Musique]